when you're reinforcing positivity to
kids around grades their athleticism or
how attractive they are it makes them
vulnerable because their self-worth
becomes in that and all of those three
things kind of change over time most
kids don't play professional sports
totally most people realize somewhere
around 23 that uh oh grades mean nothing
in real life and if you're fighting for
like looking beautiful it's a constant
game of insecurity because all of us age
so to your point if you're complimenting
kids on their energy their Ambitions
their kindness their grit and the words
coming out of their mouth
V audio experience
vaynernation what is good really excited
about today's podcast I think it's
always fun to understand understand
people's Journeys
um use it as a reference point I know my
journey resonates for some but some
can't connect because variables are
different sometimes you need to have the
person look like you or come from the
places that you came from and so on our
forever journey of finding interesting
people to have conversations with uh we
have a really good one here today that I
think is going to work for a lot of this
audience I'm going to let her introduce
herself and give you a little bit of her
background and then I'm gonna fire away
with some really fun questions and try
to tap in a little bit into what and why
and how and so Chris how are you so
great to be here Gary thank you of
course I'm Carissa [__] Bodner and I
am the CEO of thrivecon
no I I just had to bring it because
because I'm on the Gary [__] V show
today
um no I uh my name is Carissa Bodner I
am the CEO of Thrive cosmetics and by
the time this drops it's going to be
bigger than Beauty skincare it's amazing
give it go deeper what what is Thrive to
just give everyone that context and
we'll go back to how we got there I I
appreciate the prompt so very
specifically Thrive Cosmetics is spelled
c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s meaning that we
are for cause since I founded Thrive
Cosmetics we've donated over 125 million
dollars in funds and products to over
500 Charities around the world wow so
that's why we put the cause in cosmetics
but honestly we are [__] up the
industry like we are the biggest
direct-to-consumer Beauty brand in the
US we are profitable since day one I
started this out of a one bedroom
apartment and I am only here because of
the Thrive Cosmetics Community which
includes our customers customers first
and foremost I didn't have employees for
the first three years then our Charities
like our Charities the people who are
supporting cancer survivors domestic
abuse survivors veterans I just got off
the phone with one of our one of our
partners Raquel who runs self-esteem
Rising just down the road it's all about
making young women and young men feel
beautiful and confident and just love
themselves and uh and I'm I'm so blessed
I'm only here because of those people I
would have quit if I didn't have those
giving Partners telling me that that we
needed to exist so that's Thrive
Cosmetics we're vegan cruelty free we
create all of our formulas from scratch
I'm a cosmetic chemist I'm a bad [__]
on the bench that's chemistry talk for
you but but I'm I'm a philanthropist and
um and I'm so grateful for for the
opportunity to do what I do over the
last nine years at Thrive Cosmetics
we're launching our second brand bigger
than Beauty skincare where we're going
to be providing scholarships to women
underrepresented communities to get
dermatologist degrees and uh and also
estheticians licenses so
take me back to the ingredients that got
you here so when you hear all of that
when you say it out loud and if I asked
you when you hear all of that where
you're at now at this scale what was
happening in your childhood that got you
here when I think about what you said
like were you a science nerd when I
think about what you were said like were
you just hungry and ambitious when I
hear what you
said you know did something happen in
your family life or did your family have
a great cause infrastructure did
something
trigger that passion what who were you
at five six seven twelve it's a great
question Gary I I happen to think that
we may have been born with a little bit
of this hustle were you born with your
hustle yeah I think so I mean I think
when I think back to what I know about
my grandparents and my
great-grandparents then I think my
circumstance right you know I was born
in the Soviet Union and I come to the
U.S and we were so poor and it was so
clear
um that you know and my mom was we were
immigrants and my mom was cheap so you
know very early on I'm like man if I
want stuff you know right around 10 is
when it was very clear to me that like
we weren't going to Toys R Us when I was
getting something so like I vividly
remember Sega Genesis when that came out
and I wanted it and I could tell in my
mom's face that I was now a big boy and
she wasn't gonna buy that for me yeah I
think some of the hustle was instilled
in parenting and others parts of it was
based on my DNA and upbringing so let me
ask you the most important question
about what you just said were you
listening to Biggie when you bought your
Sega Genesis I wish I was if I because
then I'd be younger but since I'm older
um biggie wasn't on the scene just yet
it was more KRS one and stuff like that
okay okay Daddy Kane okay okay
yeah but you know to your point things
like sports Merit things like hip-hop
coming up the game those things always
resonated with me because they were so
close to my you know realities but what
about for you and you're gonna buy the
Jets right that's right yeah I'm gonna
buy Amazon is that your plan yeah
you know Moon you can end up on the top
of a mountain and I think people limit
you know I think it's one thing like for
me I've always actually believed that I
have a lot of friends that I meet
acquaintances business associates who
are like Gary I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna buy Tesla somebody said the other
day and I just looked at him probably
third time I've been around this person
said do you I could just feel that it
wasn't true it was like Hyperbole and I
said hey do you really think that and it
was like he took a b and he's like no
and I'm like hey
I've heard you say it three times now
I've always felt that you didn't believe
that to be true yeah I'm like you don't
need to have a big goal just to have a
big goal totally but try to create the
biggest goal that you actually think is
obtainable totally and like go forward
and so like people could say they could
buy Amazon and Facebook and Mattel and
buy a country and if I can sense that
they believe it I'm like that's huge
because then they're gonna actually try
to do it totally
um I think about that a lot with Goal
sending totally yeah I mean I had people
that thought it was crazy that I was
going to come on this podcast I'm like
garyvee doesn't even know like garyvee
doesn't even know we're gonna be like I
mean totally I mean we're already
working together no I mean so yeah I
mean it's like so if you don't believe
then No One's Gonna believe like like
literally when I so it's it's crazy this
building that we're filming in I
actually used to work for the largest
company here L'Oreal yeah they were the
first tenants here yeah yeah even before
coach that owned the building yeah yeah
and I was at 575 when L'Oreal bought the
company that I worked for Clarissa Sonic
back so many years ago I didn't even
know what L'Oreal was I didn't know to
dream this big Gary I grew up on it I
grew up on a dirt road I also so um
speaking of immigrants my my grandmother
immigrated just down the street through
Ellis Island and um came over from
Germany like I have bad [__] energy in
My DNA like I'm not gonna [__] waste
what grandma Ruth and Grandma Jackie did
for me like my grandma Jackie was like
she's an icon she she was an alcoholic
she was um she was a smoker and in her
50s quit quit drinking quit smoking
completely cold turkey went back to
school to become a drug and alcohol
counselor like if you have that bad
[__] energy in your your DNA how can
you not honor them like my grandma did
not struggle for me to not just shoot
for the moon and buy Amazon you know
what I mean like so that's so what's
happening on the dirt road like really I
want to get oh my gosh 789 yep school
sports yep siblings give me pay me a
picture so I I was born different right
like I was born different I I had this
incessant need to create I was I grew up
on a dirt road was walking door to door
to my neighbors because a lemonade stand
spoiler alert when you grow up on a dirt
road and everybody's on five or ten
acres like you don't yield that much
profit you have three potential
customers totally totally yeah so the
hustle was not happening there so what I
what I wound up doing actually was
creating in my parents kitchen so I was
I was making lipsticks I was I was
literally now the statute of limitations
has passed since I since since I was
literally stealing from Port Susan
Middle School the toilet seat covers
garyvee so next time you're on the cover
of a magazine I got you I will get you
my toilet seat covers to absorb the oil
so that you look bomb as [__] on your
cover so no I got some setting powder
for you now but like literally like I
was born with this in this this deep
passion for for living and thriving I
will say though I lost it I was I was
super depressed when I was in uh late
middle school high school
um I was bullied a lot I mean trauma
trauma like like trauma that I'm not
necessarily ready to talk about yet but
like I it what's so crazy is that with
Thrive Cosmetics like I had no idea when
I started Thrive Cosmetics I wanted to
give back to women that were going
through cancer and I wanted to make them
feel beautiful because I as a makeup
artist and I'll get to that in a second
had been so [__] blessed to see the
transformation in a woman's self-esteem
no matter what they were going through
and Men I mean I've done ton of men's
makeup so it's like what was so powerful
was that I had this Vision to help
people that were going through cancer
because I had lost my friend cancer when
I was just 23 years old she was 24.
Christy
um and and it was I I wanted to create
something that was about more than just
selling makeup and skincare I get it
like I wanted to I wanted to give back
so from the very beginning how long ago
was that nine years ago yeah I mean you
were I think one of the great things
that's going on in the world is the
conversation is more complex today and
youngsters like yourself are growing up
I mean it wasn't even a thing when I was
in high school or college where
companies would talk about doing
something with purpose attached to it
yeah right it wasn't it wasn't a norm it
wasn't an expectation it wasn't an
option yeah so the fact that you have
this tragic event you have this crazy
thirst of an entrepreneurial Spirit the
fact that you could take those two
passions together totally was like a
supernova it I'm so grateful like that's
that's the thing is like I'm not
supposed to be here like my my business
the the volume that we have done has a
[__] B next to it like that's that's
what people need to know that you can
grow up on a dirt road you can go to
Community College and if you have a
community and a passion and a vision
like I I was not people think I'm an
influencer now my first Instagram was
Thrive Cosmetics like we didn't even
have a profile but my friend Kaiser had
to tell me to put a [__] profile
photo in there like I didn't have a
profile photo and it was this community
the Thrive Cosmetics community that that
put me on and built this company from my
one bedroom apartment and now giving
over 125 million dollars like that's the
Thrive Cosmetics Community take us back
because we've got the big headlines that
I want to make sure what I'm basic just
so you know where I'm going with this
there's like three people a 50 inspired
by your grandma
B15 inspired by you listening right now
and this is the singular podcast that
changes the course of their life that's
how I think about these things I know
that to be true so one of the things I
like to do is like get one level deeper
in like little nuances that are harder
sometimes fine so let me go there yep
okay so you have this you know very
creative kid fire in the belly early on
have this period of time where you lost
your way
suicidal like I was a suicidal kid we
can go there let's [__] go listen
you're in control yeah
what you know when you you know what's
funny when when I hear something that
extreme yeah what is running through
your mind like zero self-worth yeah that
much pain in your stomach yes because of
trauma again and and so what was so
crazy is to to grow up with this bright
light inside of you yes and and also be
misunderstood like like I was like an
alien in my family like my parents loved
me but they also didn't know what to do
with me like this kid that's got so much
energy and just wants to create and is
talking to everybody and I'm like hey
like walking into garyvee's office just
being like hey what's up man like let's
talk and so you know I my parents put me
in a lot of situations like I they they
made me work for everything I got huge
um I nothing was given to me so that to
me like that's why I'm here like being
like if I would have had to or if I
would have and I say had to like if I
would have just had things given to me I
wouldn't be here hard to be hungry if
you're fat totally totally you have
siblings yeah older sister older sister
what's your relationship with her she's
awesome and you guys always were good or
had ups and downs I mean we're very
different we're
here no I mean I love my sister I love
my parents and you know
everywhere I went I mean my grandma Ruth
she would tell me how lucky I was to be
alive how like how I needed to work for
everything because she worked so hard to
to raise my dad I mean my dad was raised
like total like food stamps poverty
um my mom uh struggled a lot like but
the Grandma's a big factor in your life
yeah oh yeah that's what I say like I
started with them so fast totally yeah
and I lost my grandma that was part of
that trauma it was it was a cluster [__]
of trauma if I'm being honest got it so
there was a series of things yeah and
when do you feel like you started to get
your head up from it this is my favorite
story to tell it was future Business
Leaders of America and deca so I was a
kid with no Direction so I was this kid
that was like beautiful bright so
vivacious and so passionate about life
and then due to trauma was like suicidal
depressed
um and I never attempted anything but it
was serious yeah he's not in a good
place then somebody uh talked to me
about future Business Leaders of America
and I thought okay like I grew up in
this small town that was super
entrepreneurial Stanwood Washington town
of five thousand grew up on a dirt road
and those like I was surrounded by
entrepreneurs my parents were not
entrepreneurs my dad was a teacher
principal administrator my mom had a
bunch of different jobs so like but I
was surrounded if you wanted money like
you had to be an entrepreneur in this in
this community of Stanwood and so I got
involved in this uh this group called
future business leader of America are
you familiar oh we gotta go like it's
it's epic it's epic so it literally
transformed my life so it's a it's an
extra curricular activity that is um
throughout the US and you compete and so
you're basically I mean this is this is
I mean this is like literally you said
that I just wanted to beat up 14 year
olds in high school exactly exactly
exactly no no no seriously physically
like just beat them and okay then you
need to get involved in Deca because
that's an international competition so I
got them both titles so then let me tell
you about my Monopoly board that I I
raised 25 000 when I was um 16 years old
I was getting truancies like skipping
school my parents were like what the
hell is going on you're gonna get kicked
out of school I was like like just you
wait just you wait and then I so I made
this Monopoly board by literally going
door to door to all of the local
businesses saying I gotta I got a great
marketing opportunity for you you're
gonna pay me four hundred dollars and
and you'll get Park Place but we named
it after them so I did that all
throughout the town and it was like 40
50 people uh or companies that I got on
there and um and that paid for my cost
of goods that was the first product I
made I was 16 years commercially it's a
commercial product when you get 400
times 40 you know 40 when you get 16
like when you do that was that the first
affirmation of that like that's high
scale for a 16 year old when you're
going through that were you getting such
a high off of getting yeses from small
businesses yeah was that like when
you're going from getting shoved into
lockers being told that you're a [__]
all these things to then being on the
front page of the newspaper it doesn't
matter I was in a small town like it's
still yeah yeah and what's so epic Gary
is that 25 000 because that paid for the
cost of goods like and I can walk you
through the full p l of that first
product that I made that Monopoly board
was called twin cityopoly that that
funded so then the sales of that so
everything was profit from there of
course it was 20 to 25 depending on if
it was wholesale or or sold directly of
course all those businesses bought some
boards to sell in their own business
totally totally yeah I had people
autographing them they're asking me to
autograph them back then so cool and it
was like and but they believed in me
when I didn't even believe in myself so
that execution got you going totally it
transformed my self-esteem and then that
just propelled me I got an internship at
Nordstrom and um and the person Matt
deisher who was my mentor he was a
really big shout out Maddie D Matt
dysher woohoo uh he he's like you're
gonna be the CEO of Nordstrom he told me
that when I was 17 years old I was like
I was like okay yeah I'll be the CEO of
Nordstrom I didn't know that I didn't
know to dream that big for myself like
Gary what's so crazy is that I lived in
New York it's so crazy that I worked in
New York to me because literally I
turned down career opportunities in
Seattle Washington because I was too
scared to drive there like that that's
like I I am not I wasn't just I like I
didn't like hashtag wake up like this
but like now like literally this morning
I woke up with let's go by Lil Jon in my
head like that's like literally what's
going through my head now but but I
didn't believe I didn't know to dream
this big yeah I mean most people don't
like you know like even like one thing
that's weird about me is I've had some
fourth fifth sixth grade classmates who
I haven't talked to in years reach out
in the last decade and they're like oh
my God like you really did say you
wanted to buy the Jets in fifth grade
but at the time
I probably thought that was like a
million like I didn't even know what
that meant yeah like you're young going
through your stuff like there are things
today that are clear to me that weren't
clear seven years ago yeah ten years ago
15 years ago we're all still going
You're So Young there's gonna be CL you
know in Jesus age I get it it's my Jesus
here no no I just learned I know some of
the stuff people don't like I'm so
grateful though like and we're gonna be
doing this till we're 120 Gary I believe
it more than anything okay so how far
off are we from the Jets
you know mentally and emotionally not
very far financially far am I invited to
the party well it depends on what
happens between now and then
no sorry you were going to say something
though go ahead no I'm having so much
fun um would I really but I want to get
to your point I want to get back on
track on one thing
I'm trying to think about the building
blocks I love that story because again
now that 15 year old is gonna think
about organizations at school or at the
YMCA or something they've heard of and
like consider it now because wait I want
to do it because I'm a better like I
love that kind of [__] so what happens
next you're in Nordstroms you're
learning you have a mentor that's
[__] sees that you're [__] a liar
kid when I went through that I was an on
fire kid and a lot of people are like
you're a spaz but then occasionally
people are like uh oh you're gonna do it
yeah and you latch on to those people
that's why for everyone who's listening
if you can compliment a kid totally
especially one that you're not related
to this yeah for just the answer no for
this for this the mouth like like you
own you own who you are you know it's so
fun you just said that uh on the podcast
she like showed her face it's funny I
talk a lot about when you're reinforcing
positivity to kids around grades their
athleticism or how attractive they are
it makes them vulnerable because their
self-worth becomes in that and all of
those three things kind of change over
time like most kids don't play
professional sports totally most people
realize somewhere around 23 that uh oh
grades mean nothing in real life and if
you're fighting for like looking
beautiful as a man or woman it's a
constant game of insecurity because all
of us age like you know it's just you
know it's really hard so to your point
if you're complimenting kids on their
energy their Ambitions their kindness
their grit and uh and the words coming
out of their mouth so go ahead what
happens your Nordstrom's you're feeling
on fire What Happens Next almost
quitting school almost quitting
Community College every day like
literally I graduated because Matt
deisher was like you have to graduate
from college you're just punching your
ticket and he was trying to talk me into
an MBA and I was like I literally can't
like I I was I literally I so I went to
Bellevue Community College because I
didn't get into any other colleges I
barely applied and I mean I'm a daughter
of an educator like this is kind of
[__] up that I didn't like but I just
did not how'd your dad deal with you
being a poor student not well yeah
didn't like it yeah didn't like it I
love my dad but yeah yeah I guess that
was his Pat I get it that was his point
especially and imagine my dad growing up
on food stamps on a dirt a dirt house I
grew up on a dirt road that's a come up
from a [__] dirt house that he grew
up that was his way out I get it totally
and he's sitting here and you're he's
like I had to pay my entire way through
college I'm I'm here to support you like
all these things
um but yeah when I was I was in uh I
went to Bellevue Community College shout
out to Bellevue Community College I
think this is really important to
underscore because especially in the
Zeitgeist right now all these kids are
so obsessed with what school they're
getting into and I am here to tell you
that you can go to Bellevue Community
College and build one of the largest
beauty companies to ever exist yeah I
mean actually I would say as someone
who's a little bit older it's way better
than it used to be there are kids that
actually believe you when you say that
or believe me whereas when I was 18 or
22 it was unheard of yeah but there was
Zero people yeah at 18 in America 30
years ago that thought things could be
okay if you didn't go to college now you
have a group of kids that are definitely
in belief that there's entrepreneurship
creativity creators there's many other
options the problem is sometimes it
skews the other way and they're like
[__] college but they don't realize that
means you have to eat so much [__] so
much [__] and work so [__] you got a
crawl before you ball you got a crawl
before you ball and the the dream is
free and the hustle is sold separately
and that that is the thing like again
I've been doing this for nine years and
I love that for us like I love that I
didn't sell the company I love that I'm
here to just build build build give give
because like
quitting is actually harder for me than
trying like like I don't want like I I
literally can't quit these people like
that we named like if you look at my
eyeshadow right now I have Raquel on me
I've got Betty on me like I've got we
literally name our products after
inspiring people and and like I can't
quit these people like because these are
you also like it totally yeah no and I
mean I love the chemistry when you said
crawl before you bought I love that I
haven't heard that my brain went to
literally I didn't want to interrupt you
but my brain went to crawl
period Well I can't like I can't take
credit because it's Kanye West got it
yeah so crawl yeah crawl yeah like if
you love it so much you'll just crawl
yeah you'll just [__] crawl totally
like to me that is the vulnerability of
so many entrepreneurs they're so focused
on balling yep that they want to get out
of crawling as fast as possible thus
rendering them never to be bawling
totally totally I mean and not like when
you're like saying Betty somebody like
but I'm also sitting here I'm like yeah
but you love it too totally yeah it
doesn't it doesn't feel like work I I
literally tell my team I'm like let's go
in the [__] lab like it's not
coveted anymore like I can go back on
the bench and create formulas
my team's all over me I don't want to
run a time you're in Nordstroms when do
you get into like yeah I'll give you the
Twitter version I'll try Nordstrom
Sephora at the same time worked as a
makeup artist worked on the sales floor
eleven dollars an hour Nordstrom I was
just hustling I was working like 50 60
hours because if I wanted something
that's like that's how I was able to pay
cash work in retail totally
which was incredible like like literally
if it all goes away I'll go back to
Sephora tomorrow I love Sephora I don't
want to sell our products at Sephora but
I love Sephora it was a great experience
for me so I worked at Sephora always
wanted to be in product development
thank God I didn't know that Clarisonic
was right down the road from Bellevue
Community College because I would have
quit I literally would have quit Gary
because I was like I'm gonna do product
development I'm gonna do product
development instead of doing my homework
at night time for college I was
literally getting a D in the most basic
rocks for jocks classes like
environmental science and nutrition
because I was studying formulations at
nighttime reading the Cosmetic
ingredient dictionary that's my life
yeah totally I literally
like
look raids in high school I literally
got a D in food survey
Serbia like we would just sit and put
food in the microwave let me give you
some other D driver's ed d
how hard it is to get a D in driver's ed
like this is insane [__] like I got a D
in health yeah yeah like no same same
here's and all we had to do this
say out loud what I got a D in in
sophomore year
speech D good for you Beach good for you
think about how insane that is I am
literally might actually get paid to do
that like genuinely actually one of the
most successful public speakers in the
world right now and I got a D in [__]
speech I get it you were doing your
passion yeah and just trying to get by
yeah to because Maddie D said you just
need it as a backup totally like [__] it
I will do that yeah totally like I went
to night school like I was with her with
50 years old and I'm all right so you're
there because I wanted to get the whole
thing yeah so then I so I I worked
formulas but I got whatever job I could
get at Clarisonic my first title was was
marketing assistant and I was like okay
I'll take this marketing assistant and
tell everybody what Clarisonic is
Clarisonic it was I mean it was iconic
it was Sonicare for your face yeah
L'Oreal bought it and then they shut it
down which is why I won't sell my brand
of course you love L'Oreal love L'Oreal
Hamilton I love you but like you know
like I'm not doing that I literally
cannot quit these people who have like
our customers are our greatest investors
our giving Partners let me completely
switch the vibe from the youngsters on
the come up to the people much further
along right here in this spot
when you so emphatically say I'm not
gonna quit Betty Betty I hear you
no [__] here this is actually a fun
question because I deal with this
are you scared to ever get an offer that
is so insane
that it's going to put your back against
the like do you realize when you're so
emphatic publicly that I'm never gonna
sell that it eliminates options that may
matter to you when you're 43 57 16 like
how do you think about that I you know
you understand what I'm saying oh of
course yeah I mean how big of an offer
you think I've turned down for this
company
a billion dollar value more commas that
I can literally yeah yeah [__] up some
commas yeah yeah that was yeah but yeah
but you're extremely in that Prime spot
right now so like the first nine years
of Thrive Cosmetics were not as good as
they are right now no [__] yeah you're
in a great like you're in a fun spot
right now like the building up is the
best like when you're that person yeah
the life cycles that you're still to go
through May create scenarios where you
may want the options and like I always
think about like when I'm I basically
tell my whole company if I ever sell
Vayner you have to quit the next day
because no matter what I say it won't be
the same company totally when you dig
yourself in that hole I always think
about the mindset of that that's truly
burning the boat yeah totally and I love
it I I love it I didn't I didn't start
this journey I mean I could I can walk
you through every m a transaction that
has that has happened since 2014. I know
all the numbers in my head of course all
the numbers in my head and yeah I'm the
industry baby like Lil Nas X uh so I uh
uh I am the industry baby I started when
I was 25. like and now I'm the industry
like that's and but that's it's we are
the industry it's not me I get it and
but what so so first of all I reserve
the right to change my mind at any time
love but I am here to tell you that
Carissa Bodner has turned down the
offers that she would have thought when
she was 10 years old 13 years old 15
years old 25 years old yeah yeah yeah I
didn't if I sell I'm quitting if I sell
it's because I'm quitting because I
don't think I can do it anymore that's
the thing it's it's like and I can't
quit Betty I can't quit Raquel I can't
nollie like like I I mean some of the
people what was because I'm gonna run
out of time what was the what was the
if I asked you why were you able to get
this big from a marketing product
strategy standpoint what do you think of
the one or two bullet points that you
saw in the last nine years that the
competitive set did it maniacal Focus
maniacal focus on formulation and giving
back like I I've never wavered in that
it's not a trend right we are not a
trend we're not trying to trender yeah
like literally that's who we are the
amount of people that have have said
that this is a marketing Trend or
whatever like like literally we develop
our formulas from scratch you cannot the
amount of time shout out to L'Oreal for
buying Thrive Cosmetics products to try
and reformulate them at the lab that I
[__] worked at
we block those orders we're 100 D to C I
got turned down and also so so maniacal
Focus you can drown an opportunity we
know that and an excellence in product
and customer service we're not perfect
also also just knowing that we're not
perfect and being willing to evolve and
and like I mean bigger than Beauty
skincare is a 40 reduction in the in the
plastic that we have um from Thrive
Cosmetics because we've heard loud and
clear we need to be more sustainable
like I am only here because of our
customers you let you learned that at
retail I mean you listen and I learn
every day of course I was but but I want
to jump in here I apologize because I
want people to hear this going retail
is a monster win because at Sephora and
Nordstroms you learn very quickly that
if you listen to them you will sell them
[__] but we don't sell at retail I know
you don't yeah but you're listening to
your customers yes yes no no I know that
you don't sell at retail but you sell
product to Consumers but that's the
thing with the beauty industry they
listen to Sephora no disrespect to
Sephora love them Nordstrom they should
not be driving your product pipeline
your customers should you should and
that is that's the issue with all the
other beauty brands of course because
for L'Oreal and Procter for all the
biggest brands in the world that's their
distribution the retailer has the
leverage when you're DTC nobody has
leverage but you're a customer totally
you're not unless you're listening to
your customer because you have no
[__] Choice yeah and also because
it's a privilege it's a privilege and it
is a pleasure I get some of the best
ideas from our community our giving
Partners have like we literally
developed a sunscreen with beauty to the
streets uh surely uh rains she's she's a
star you should have her on your show
she has literally humanized the
population of Skid Row like and we get
to do that together with her we she said
Chris I need a sunscreen I needed to be
a bomb ass sunscreen too so that's what
we developed like filtered effects SPF
37 like that's that's literally what is
happening with our giving partners and
it's it's so magical and it's such a
privilege and for somebody who just
wanted to work in the industry just
wanted to develop products the fact that
I get to develop products give back
literally we started a scholarship with
Brianna Taylor's family and University
of Louisville like how can I quit that
how can I quit that Gary like how could
I ever do that
like you said you were tired and you
decided to quit but until then you do it
forever yeah talk to me take a beat here
because we're wrapping up what didn't we
touch on that you want to touch on for
the audience
that you can literally be anything you
want to be at any age like I was 25
years old and so many people were like
who's running your company like I'm the
only c-level executive Thrive Cosmetics
has ever had
like you can be whoever you want to this
day yeah I'm I'm gonna hire you're
scared to give somebody a c-suite item
no not at all no because I couldn't
afford employees so literally yeah but
Gary like you can you can throw bodies
at a problem but like I care I care
about our company culture and it's been
it's been an ebb and flow and I and I I
so I have a VP layer now and I'm working
on building out the c-suite but like you
can be
whoever you want to be you're never too
young or too old to be who you or too
old to be who you wanted to be like do
you know training with drone on
Instagram she's 77 didn't move her body
until she was 70. she was overweight
couldn't move her body she runs 10 miles
per hour on the treadmill stories yeah
unlimited so it's like to me that's so
that's my inspiration as train would
jump and I want to be trained with Joan
okay so it's like for me I never want to
stop grinding and I am so so driven by
this beautiful community of Charities
that we get to support and our customers
because again I am only here because of
them I get it so thank you for being on
thank you so much garyvee
foreign
[Music]